so I I really think that healing is
something that can take place also in a
relationship but you have had to have
done the bulk of the work for yourself
do you think that healing needs to have
therapy so there's some tangible result
because it's like if you're just talking
to your friends like they're more likely
to tell you what you want to hear where
a therapist will like sit you down and
tell you about yourself
and I'm currently doing therapy right
now and at first I was just like this is
like what white people do like no
literally because no no literally is
this is literally my thought process and
even all the people around me when I
finally told them I'm going to do
therapy they're like what are you doing
therapy for that's like white people
stuff it completely changed my life like
completely the first thing I realized
was there's a lot of internal dialogue
that I have going on in myself and I
have an expectation that the people who
are closest to me should be able to
gauge accurately how I feel because I
intuitively am able to like know when
something is wrong with the people who
are closest to me so I always felt that
there wasn't a balance of skills let's
say so having that conversation is not
just about oh how do you feel they
really untangled the mental mess that's
in your mind and lay everything straight
in front of you to allow you to deal
with it so it's a life skill that you
can take anywhere the workplace
friendships like so yeah they start from
the beginning so on one side women tend
to use words to grandiose their
predicament toxic healing trauma
I was I was going to say so when you
were saying that you kind of um you know
this healing thing and going on vacation
vacation Etc to my mind from my
experience because because I've been
with women who are kind of healing
[Laughter]
and it just seems to me that they're
they're waiting for an emotional
stimulus that has you know a greater
impact than their previous guy so so
women want to sleep up no no one heals
and gets with like a really nice guy who
treated their lives she gets with like a
child in Thailand and then she's like yo
[ __ ] the last guy you know I can do
better I'm empowered then she comes back
and you know even the therapy thing I've
met a lot of crazy women who do therapy
yeah and most of the time when they tell
me about their thoughts on what they
think in therapy I just get a lot of
feminist rhetoric I I get a lot of like
using these words and this that to kind
of say things are actually quite simple
that is like
why would you expect people to know why
you think though because people well
some women like to be like to present
themselves as complex and deep and
especially when they're on their healing
Journey they want to come across as oh
I've done the work I'm now woke I'm very
aware of myself but then their actions
don't reflect what it is that they're
saying to me someone who is healing is
someone who I think like you said Amber
has actually taken time out so I'm going
to be really quick
November or December last year I cut
someone who was completely toxic off not
only did I cut him off I cut 98 of
people off and I'm talking extended
family like no one knew where Linda was
people on my social media if they see
this they'll be like yeah she
disappeared like it's only June that I
came back and even when before that even
when men were approaching me I will tell
them Point Blank I have gone through
something very like traumatizing I need
a time like to just deal with myself and
you're someone else's son I'm not gonna
put that onto you and 98 of them was
like well that's really honest I respect
you for that and some sort of basic
friendship or connection was maintained
not every day but like on my socials do
you know what I mean okay I can see your
facial expressions you're like what are
you talking about but I'm very like I
know what I'm saying okay but so cutting
off 98 of people you say yeah do you
think do you think that's like healthy
especially it was healthy for me because
I'm a giver so because I'm constant only
someone who I used to have a thing of
if someone did something I'd be like
but how do they feel if I react and pull
myself away from them rather than being
like no what you did something wrong I
love me enough to take a step back and
cut you off because you're now no longer
entitled to my presence so a lot of
people yeah my presence because I know
what I offer in every friendship in
every relationship in every Dynamic so I
had to realize that I need to take back
my energy
and just do me and it was the best thing
that I did for six months I've never
been so selfish in my life I think so
you healed by being selfish yes because
I'm a selfless person uh-huh like don't
you that kind of sounds like you would
have the opposite effect because because
you'd go to the next guy and say the
last six months I've been selfish date
me no that's not it because
I'm telling you I'm telling you how this
sounds tonight what did you do in your
six months I did indoor rock climbing I
went swimming I painted I started a
novel I started I did things for me so
it's funny Andrew Tate talks about this
how women will talk like they're the men
they want to date so like if we wanted
to date a guy those are things that like
we'd want to hear about and to hear that
he'd done but like the guys don't care
about that I wouldn't bring up unless
they asked okay but don't you think so
for example right so when I hear about
that Journey
um you said like the therapist made you
more accountable right that was like my
first therapist so I chose to do that
yeah okay but surely if you characterize
98 of your relationships are so toxic
that they're worthy of being caught off
at you know some some short notice
because
you are a giver which in my mind sounds
like you lack the self-control to
adequately manage healthy boundaries
then you know I'm not being rude but
that doesn't sound as much
accountability as a very complex way of
digging yourself up but that's part of
the journey not everyone's gonna get it
at that point so it took me two years
and a few more situations to realize
Linda you've got a poor issue with
boundaries
you are not gonna if someone comes and
tells you you have an issue or if a girl
calls you about the same issue and you
get tired of her telling you about the
same issue you leave her alone and
hopefully if she self if she is someone
who is self-reflective over time you
hope that that person sits with themself
until they realize their own mess and
realize I need to change couldn't you
just say stop talking about this [ __ ]
but that's for that person I can't speak
for them oh but I'm talking yeah I'm
talking in relation to myself okay I
thought you were saying like you were
tired of listening no no no no that was
just a random example Oh I thought this
was no no
you seem like you have something else to
say I'm just I'm just curious as to like
what what are the new relationships if
you built kind of have you somewhat
replaced a portion of that 98 so with
the people that left there were people
that also remained and these were people
who would like once a month Linda I know
you're taking time up for yourself I
respect your your thing what you're
doing just letting you know that I'm I'm
sending you love so once I was ready to
go back and be on socials and be around
people those small group of people I'll
say about 10 to 15 were the people that
I kept really close to me because they
understood my boundaries they understood
what I was doing and interestingly
enough they were all kind of like
working on themselves as well 10 to 15
people yeah that's a lot so so how many
I know you want to go into the 98 how
many was that how many people was that
so that was extended family because I
needed to focus on self people on social
media that I don't know because there
was a lot of things that I used to do on
socials people hit me up in the DMS and
it was too overwhelming for me on
Twitter and on Instagram and I was like
I can't do this I can't deal with this
anymore
so how many people was that
do you want to go look at my socials
both Twitter and Instagram then you can
work it out so what did you used to do
sorry I apologies I need to know okay so
between 20 2012 to 2016 I ran my own
Publishing Company
produced four magazines glossy titles
everything independently myself and my
partner at the time
left that got into the workforce and
everything and then I've always done
things to do with like podcasting like
I'm here now today or like filming I
used to do active stuff like extras like
I was in Holby City for a bit like as an
extra I've always done creative things
so along the way I've met tons of people
who remember me or remember my
interactions those are the bulk of the
people who are on my socials and support
me or whatever so yeah
so and those are the people that were so
toxic you you cut them off
oh I told you about a toxic relationship
last year that I got off so therefore I
decided to cut off 98 of people okay
there's two different including people
like this why what should be the People
You Meet actually those were the people
on my socials that I felt were quite
overwhelming because I didn't want to
always respond to their DMS and at that
point boundaries were a bit shaky for me
sorry
I've got something to say okay
do you just feel like you just wanted
space yes because I felt I couldn't like
I couldn't bloody breathe yeah I think
the short of it is
you just wanted space yeah you wanted
time for you yeah you didn't want to
really be dealing with a lot of people
or be so you had selective few people
that you had to deal with yeah and other
than that you just wanted your space
yeah I think it's more that sometimes we
just need space like not every day you
want to talk to people no of course
especially you know what I mean I'm a
massive fan not every day you wanna not
every day we wanna be happy sometimes we
want to get up we're pissed off did
someone say that you can't you can't
feel it you said you can't fully heal
right or something along them lines or
am I reaching yeah someone said that all
right cool now I said sometimes you
probably can't fully heal all right cool
so do the training but there's still
tiny little elements of you that are
still going to happen have you ever yeah
I'm guessing most of us have heard that
saying if it's not a blessing it's a
lesson yeah right cool so for me healing
is like when you can go through a
situation and be like it's not affecting
me no more I've learned yeah it's not
like because I get that what baggage is
like for example if someone broke your
trust in a previous relationship you're
going to move that you might move that
to another relationship but it's how you
move it there's a difference you're
paranoid now
which you didn't get the blessing you
know I mean I meant you didn't get the
lesson out of that or you can be a bit
cautious which is a normal reaction so I
feel like you can heal in it it's just
about how you doing how you deal with it
giving it enough time I know enough
people that get out of a toxic
relationship give it a month in another
relationship yes and you're like what
are you doing you're still dealing with
your problems that's because they don't
know how to
stay single like some people they they
have these strong needs to be in a
relationship to fulfill that void that
they feel so maybe you can heal properly
just a lot of people don't do it the
right way yeah exactly I can't
articulate why but when I hear people
talk about healing it just sounds like
nonsense and I can't I can't articulate
why do you know what I get what you mean
but I can't so personal yeah it's about
perception and put I get what you mean
though I do so I think it just sounds
like a fishing like you're gonna do one
person one person was alone for six
months one person went on a trip one
person yeah I get what you mean though I
don't for romance perspective we don't
really care about hearing about no heat
no but it depends though like if you're
dealing with someone already they say
they don't know what I was talking about
him no but let's say they're going to
kill dogs
that's healed already
why'd you want to be out here putting
pluses on people all the time
I heard that oh so
58 of people how does that make you a
better girlfriend in six months has
nothing to do with a relationship it had
everything to do with me and how I felt
and from my mental health well I'm just
thinking like from the guy's point of
view so I'm like yeah that's not
something I'll just run into a
relationship and be like oh so by the
way I'm healing obviously like that's
gonna scare anybody I'm like he knew
from what you'd be surprised but you
know what I just realized men don't say
they're healing I've never heard a man
say well that's because
well no I think I think men like women
kind of dramatize things like I think
we're kind of more dramatic like it's a
bit dramatic to cut off 98 of people for
six months it worked for me yeah I mean
I'm not saying I don't I don't know you
I don't know what's but I'm just saying
like men are like okay I took that album
and move on yeah yeah we're girls we're
girls they'll either go and say oh I had
a to heal in my whole face is or I had
to heal and cut everybody off or I had
to heal like this this 90 of the time I
do feel like healing is an excuse or a
cover-up for I'm about to go wild right
now which is I mean like that's what
Jada that's what Jada Pinkett women yeah
oh yeah I mean I mean what did what did
Jada say on on the red table talk she
said it's a season of healing and that's
like the like that sounds nuts
and what did she do she she screwed up
her daughter's drug addict friends yeah
she said she was healing him yeah
she wouldn't even heal yourself though
she was eating yeah
everything but it is about perception
though to an extent because it's like my
healing can be different to everyone's
either yeah
but that's like confusing because a lot
of times girls will use words and like
we can't even agree on what they mean
yeah so it just kind of comes off as
like nonsense to men but it doesn't
matter it matters to human it makes
sense to you what I'm saying when you're
communicating to other people it does
matter that they can understand you yeah
you need to yeah
there's that but I think we need to it's
both ways though I feel like like if you
wanna let's say you're only healing to
no alcohol not only your healing Aid to
better yourself as an individual and B
to then be ready for another
relationship because be around others
yeah exactly so yeah I get like in that
aspect any of like yeah that's nothing
yeah but it's just it's just when we say
healing a lot of times there's no
nothing tangible that anyone could say
you're a better person now than you were
six months ago it's just like oh some
time has passed I didn't talk to people
or oh I went on a vacation or oh I went
I rode the seat what are they called it
I would disagree I
um was in a relationship for quite some
time anyway it didn't work out as these
things sometimes do and I got really
angry and I got really aggressive at
this person and I was heartbroken and
then I had to take a while for myself to
realize actually a lot of that the red
flags were there but I still sat back
and let things ride and what have you
and a big part of healing if you want to
say that you know for me was celibacy
yeah and I've been celibate for two and
a half years as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible